Samuel you see I hope you having a great
day and in this video I want to talk a
little bit about brexit should you wait
for brexit to all be announced properly
and finished before investing in
property or should you get it now what's
going to happen in the future so if
you're interested in that please stay
tuned okay brexit what's going to happen
well the truth is I don't know exactly
what's gonna happen
no one does even the people in high
places I don't think know exactly what's
going to happen but the question is
what's going to happen in the property
market and I'll give you my opinion on
that so it's possible that if we
depending on the deal what happens that
we the properties will dip that's quite
possible however we live on a small
island in England in the UK we run a
small island and there's a massive
massive shortage of houses there's an
overpopulation of people so long-term I
do not I cannot possibly see how a price
is gonna be a big crash and properties
are gonna be worth peanuts it's just
never ever ever gonna happen so there
could be a little bit interestingly
since bricks it was announced a year and
a half two years ago since it was
announced in my home town property
prices have gone up by over 30% so
property prices are they're not as
stagnant as you might think they're not
as dicey as you might think now in
London there's been a debt but that's
got nothing to do with brexit the reason
that a dip in London is because there's
previously was a massive expansion and
where there's an expansion will always
follow a dip a recession that's always
gonna happen
so we brakes it a lot of uncertainty no
one knows for sure exactly what's gonna
happen
prices may go down next year only to go
up again but I see right now is a
massive massive opportunity and here's
why because there's a lot of landlords
who only see the news they get all their
information not from my YouTube channel
not from people that are actually making
a lot of money in there that they just
watch the news the media and they see
these crazy news articles about Brick
City and what's gonna happen and then
these landlords get scared and because
they're scared because they think the
prices are certainly gonna drop like
crazy which I don't feel mad well
what they do it is they're selling their
portfolios up pretty good prices because
they want to sell quick because they're
motivated because they want to do it
before the whole brexit crazy thing
happens so actually that's quite a good
opportunity for you and for me because
we're I mean I personally be buying
people people's whole portfolios
recently and so many of my stews not
only have I been buying and my students
have been buying portfolios but we've
also been taking on property portfolios
on a lease option agreement so there's a
massive massive opportunity right now
even if property prices do go down as
long as you're getting your return on
investment unless you're buying to sell
it doesn't matter anyway so my thoughts
on brexit is don't wait because what
most people wait most people are well
see what happens and then they wait and
they wait and in that waiting time where
people are scared that's when you should
be being greedy and then when the
waiting finishes and people are actually
ok our properties are going back up
again that don't sue me that's a that's
a bad time that's a bad time because
that's when people are getting thumped
all the while if the whole world was
saying now's a great time to invest it
probably is not a great time to invest
if everyone's saying mmm I'm not sure
that's probably a good time to get in so
if you've been waiting to see what
happens stop right now
get educated stop buying the right
properties that give you the right
returns that mean that you're going to
make an income you're not planning on
selling it anyway so that's kind of
where I'm coming from most my
positioning on brexit but we'll see what
happens I'm very interested to see what
happens I've looked in on your thoughts
please do comment below if this video
has been helpful share it and I'll see
you next time